an excerpt from a video by artists
Matias venca and Michelin cough one is
the subject and the other is the
cameraman the duo are not afraid to take
risks or break the law to create their
stunning shots
they'll go to almost any height in the
name of art but the stunts are not as
reckless as they look they prepare their
performances long in advance and
calculate the risks involved they ask em
kind of there are no safety nets in life
our works are like feed back to real
life sometimes we don't know what will
happen there may appear to be an element
of safety where there is not let me film
mrs. Caffey food it's not about making
it look dangerous it's about seeing and
feeling what we expose ourselves to and
there are no limits for us they
discovered this world war 2 flak tower
in a park in Vienna while preparing for
an exhibition in the city
the site is off-limits to the public and
largely forgotten the artists managed to
gain access and add the tower to their
guerrilla performances in urban public
spaces
no but it's as if there are lots of
places that aren't normally very
interesting if you're just walking past
them but if you stop and look closely
you'll find lots of interesting aspects
it's consumed us as artists it's
important to see the playful aspect and
what kind of potential this place might
have aside from its intended function of
input until they presented the results
in a video
it was featured at their first
exhibition in Vienna also on display a
photo of the tower complete with the
banner they attach to it many of the
duo's works are dangerous and illegal
but to the gallery goers the daredevil
aspect is not the essential point
although hometown it's about the
conquest of the architecture something I
see only a second or third glance
hey wait there's something crawling on
it oh that's a person this means once
yeah he's taking possession in a very
tactile way which we're not able to do
because we can only experience it
visually it's exciting from scaling
smokestacks in Prague to climbing
skyscrapers in Tokyo the performers body
always becomes a graphic element in the
image a symbol in the cityscape the
compositions are carefully thought
through the danger seems to be of
secondary importance it's been done
divorced in the moment when I do this
I'm very conscious of the moment and as
I get older I enjoy these moments more
and more when I managed to make a dream
reality and to do the things that up to
then I'd only envision for a new-build
I'm coaxing
the films have a poetic serene quality
with the danger barely perceptible this
conflict is what makes the art of Matias
Bianca and Michelin cough so powerful
and what has already earned them several
awards the question now is how far this
risky road will take them
because in Tata we've reached a point
where things are starting to change
we're trying to reduce the images to the
essential and we've realized that the
risk aspect is getting in the way that
many viewers just can't see past the
danger and appreciate the imagery for
what it is so we're looking for some way
to reduce that aspect yeah of not
invasive this also games
whichever way their art goes from here
the duo's daring exploits are not over
yet